starting to piss me off I'm coming for
your heads and so the as
sleepness in those patterns is there is
a little pin holes and so if these
catalysts get into those little pin
holes where the program is running there
can be like an explosion that happens of
that program and there can be like a
glitch that happens and then from The
Matrix programming there can be a shift
to the new Earth the show is generating
those catalysts that get into those
little pin holes of those contracted
programs that then shatter them out of
the Matrix and into building new Earth
and that ignites the warrior within to
die into the Transcendent game and
that's your GG right there